son prix peut varier de 400 à 1000 euros
le kilo en fonction de l'offre et de la
demande la récolte des truffes basse son
plein normalement entre décembre et mars
mais cette année le diamant noir c'est
fait rare au pied des chênes truffiers
la faute aux conditions climatiques les
explications de Sarago oui donc la plus
grosse donc fait 57 G
et la plus petite est fait 7 g et le
tout mais trois 57 G
c'est une bonne récolte non c'est une
récolte catastrophique
une récolte catastrophique pour Alain
Godin et beaucoup d'autres cultivateurs
de truffes cette année sur ces deux
hectares à saint-maurent de Touraine ce
truciculteur n'atteindra pas le kilo
cette saison une récolte 50 fois moins
importantes que l'an passé le climat des
mois dernier serait la principale cause
pour le moment de facteurs sont-elles
études on n'a pas beaucoup d'éléments à
part les éléments météorologiques et qui
ont pu influer effectivement sur les
naissances de la truffe sur le le
grossissement des truffes etc et ces
facteurs c'est bien sûr
la canicule donc des températures très
élevées et puis un déficit hydrique très
important parce qu'on a quasiment pas eu
de pas eu d'eau pendant deux mois des
éléments annuansés selon le président de
l'association des trufficulteurs de
Touraine pour lui difficile d'établir
des certitudes il s'agit davantage d'un
concert de facteurs je pense que l'âge
des plantations a aussi son importance
parce qu'il y a des gens qui ont fait
été très bonnes une très bonne année il
y a des gens qui ont fait une année
catastrophique mais on voit aussi qu'en
fonction des âges des âges des
plantations la production de truffe et
pas la même des productions différentes
mais globalement mauvaises à l'échelle
nationale dans la région près d'une
tonne et demi de truffes ont été
récoltés cette année un chiffre deux
fois moins élevé que la saison passée